well folks the the Oscars were last
night and it's pretty exciting stuff it
appears that this in that movie won and
people were upset because this happened
and that happened this person wore an
outrageous outfit so on and so forth
yada yada etc that's my coverage of the
Academy Awards I couldn't make myself
care about this kind of thing if you
paid me and well actually I guess I am
paid to care about the news but but I
still don't care about this I just I
just can't I can't manage to do it all I
all I ever think about when I went you
know when I when I see that something
like the Academy Awards is on all I ever
can think is what must the space aliens
think the space aliens that I'm sure are
somewhere out there on planet galvatron
or whatever and they're watching our our
television feed and they see something
like the the Academy Awards and they see
you know three and a half hours of
people congratulating themselves and
then other people sit around in their
homes and watch those people
congratulate themselves what must the
aliens think they must be they must be
very confused about it as they plot
their mission to come in take over the
world and enslave mankind which is a in
invent and eventualities a Thai person
aliy welcome now I do have a lot - a lot
of I think more interesting things to
talk about today though and we're gonna
get to all that but before we do let's
check in with policy genius you know
getting life insurance can can feel like
like a jigsaw puzzle sometimes it's very
confusing especially in my case because
I'm a very easily confused person like I
wanted to toast a bagel yesterday and I
had to look up a YouTube tutorial and
spend three hours studying before I
toasted the bagel so I'm very easily
confused but even if you're not like me
even if you're smarter than me it still
is a difficult thing to do life
insurance can be pretty daunting yet if
you have kids if you have a family if
you have a mortgage any of the above
it's something that you got to figure
out policy genius is the easy way to get
life insurance emphasis on easy and
quick - so that means in just two men
so you can compare quotes from top
insurers to find the best policy you
know if they're worried about all the
red tape and all that kind of stuff
because when you apply online the
advisors of policy genius will take care
of all that for you they'll take the
lead they'll get you through the process
and they'll even negotiate your rate
with the insurance company there's no
hidden fees or anything like that to
worry about no commissioned sales agents
what you see is what you get helpful
advice personalized service that's it so
if you find life insurance confusing
like I do go to policy genius.com in two
minutes you can compare quotes you can
find the right policy save up to 40% and
you don't have to take on this puzzle by
yourself without some help I would
recommend that you don't life insurance
is definitely more confusing than
toasting a bagel I could tell you that
unless you have policy genius the easy
way to compare and buy life insurance
okay
now I don't know where to begin let's
just start with this on Friday a bunch
of children with something called the
sunrise movement which is apparently an
environmentalist group they went into
senator Feinstein's office Dianne
Feinstein they went into her office in
DC to harass her for not supporting the
insane green New Deal now Feinstein who
as I'm sure you know is is no friend to
the conservative movement I'm not a fan
of hers at all to put a mildly but she
for the last few days has been unfairly
maligned for allegedly being
disrespectful to these poor little
children who went to her office to talk
to her about the green New Deal that's
the impression that was supposedly given
by the two-minute video that I'm about
to show you a video that of course what
do you know has been edited to make her
look bad because the full video tells a
different story
and I'll get to the I'll get to that in
a minute but but for now let's just take
a look let's take a look at the
deceptive video here's the here's the
two-minute video that this
environmentalist group put out
[Music]
we're trying to ask you to vote YES on
the green new day please okay I'll tell
you what we have our own green new deal
scientists have said that we have 12
years to turn this around well it's not
gonna get turned around in 10 years what
we can do in 10 years you're looking at
the faces of the people who are gonna be
living with for the people by the people
and know what's interesting about this
group it's I've been doing this for 30
years I know what I'm doing you come in
here and you say it has to be my way or
the highway I don't respond to that I've
gotten elected
I just ran I was elected by almost a
million vote plurality and I know what
I'm doing so you know maybe people
should listen a little bit I hear what
you're saying but where are the people
who voted you you're supposed to listen
to us that's your how old are you I'm 16
I have seven grandchildren I understand
it very well no no the cost of not
taking this action is far higher than
the cost of what the green new deal will
be and there is an enormous popularity
for this bill around the whole country
here's we're asking you to be brave and
do this for us and for your
grandchildren I'm trying to do the best
I can which was to write a responsible
resolution a plan that doesn't take full
transformative action is not going to be
what we need well you know better than I
do
so I think one day you should run for
the Senate I love you do it your world
by that time there's by just one a
little work
okay now as I said that of course is not
the full story because it never is and
here's the thing at some point we all
have to learn this lesson and I'm not
sure why so many people still struggle
to understand that listen when you see a
video online that everybody is getting
outraged about and you see the video is
a two minute or 30 second or 1 minute
clip of some sort of out of context
discussion or event or altercation just
assume right away just assume for the
very beginning that it's misleading and
that there's more to the story just in
every single time assume that so
whenever people are getting outraged
over a two-minute out-of-context clip
that you can tell has been there when
parts cut out and there was parts before
that and parts after that that you don't
see just assume that there's just just
assume it don't join the outrage you
could just know right away there is
definitely more to this story okay
somebody took this part of the exchange
and they left out the rest and there's a
reason for that so if you look at the
the whole video is like 15 minutes and
if you look at that you see that
Feinstein was actually incredibly
patient with these kids way more patient
that I would be she even offered one of
them an internship which what do you
know the the good folks at the sunrise
movement decided to cut that part out I
wonder why they cut that out because
obviously they have agenda Genda but but
but here's the thing even even in that
that short two-minute video even if
that's all there there was to it I'm
still totally on the side of Dianne
Feinstein and I don't get to say that
very often but I am in this case she was
not the one being disrespectful
those kids were being disrespectful to
her she's the adult in this situation
remember she's like 85 years old and
these are and these are little kids
and little kids that have come into her
office and are lecturing her and tried
to instruct her on what she needs to do
um did you hear that the one girl in
particular was I just I couldn't even
watch her the first time I saw that
video I had to look away because I was
just cringing and especially as a parent
I was just I mean that one girl
particular to let your job let me tell
you what your job is although I did
appreciate the part when they said when
they said but were your voters you need
to listen us and she said well but
you're 16 you're not my voters you
didn't vote for me now you know I I'm
old-fashioned so I still believe in
respecting your elders and that's
something that you got to teach kids so
kids don't talk to adults that way
that's not how I'm raising my kids you
don't go and talk to an adult doesn't
matter if she's a senator or if she's a
janitor doesn't matter who she is
you don't talk to an adult that way you
need to have respect for adults now but
I don't blame the kids really for their
awful and a bare and embarrassing
behavior and it was awful and
embarrassing and if those are my
children I would be totally ashamed I
would be ashamed of their behavior be
ashamed of myself I'd be ashamed of
myself especially so yeah I blame the
parents for this when I was a kid if I
ever spoke to an elderly woman like that
I'd be at home right now grounded and
writing a heartfelt letter of apology a
letter of apology that my dad would be
um you know checking and and then making
editorial comments and making me go back
and write it again like that's that's
that's how I'd be spending my day is
working on this letter of apology to the
woman that I had terribly disrespected
disrespected but I had competent parents
you know actually who actually cared
about forming me into a at least
somewhat respectable adult but these
children apparently don't and when you
don't have competent parents guiding you
and instructing you on how to behave
especially around your elders then you
can't really be expected
to figure it out on your own kids donut
don't figure that kind of stuff out like
if you don't tell a kid and work with a
child to be respectful they're not gonna
just figure it out then it just becomes
Lord of the Flies and you're gonna end
up with bratty kids like that so I blame
this on the parents and I'll tell you
something else that I blame on the
parents and on the adults around these
kids and this is the thing that really
jumped out at me that this is what makes
that video so disturbing more than the
utter disrespect of these bratty kids
it's how truly scared they seem to be I
mean these kids really think the world's
gonna end
they really do in and they think that
because that's what they've been told
climate alarmism climate alarmism has
become a doomsday cult it is more than
just alarmism now it is a it is like
doomsday you know Jim Jones territory
that we're in now these maniacs and when
I say maniacs I'm not talking about the
kids I'm talking about the adults these
maniacs are running around screaming
that the world is going to end that
that's literally what they're doing
they're saying the world is coming to an
end for example here's a here's a clip
from good ol AOC Alexandria okay so
Cortes here she is last month saying
that the world is coming to an end
I think that the part of it that is
generational is that Millennials and
people have you know Gen Z and all these
folks that come after us are looking up
and we're like the world is going to end
in 12 years if we don't address climate
change and your biggest issue is your
your biggest issue is how are we gonna
pay for it and like this is the war this
is our world war two the world is going
to end in 12 years she says 12 years she
even put she put a time limit on it I
mean that that's what the doomsday
cultists do that's what the cult leaders
do is they give you an exact you know
date when the world's going in and
that's what and that's what she's doing
here
these are doomsday prophets predicting
the exact date of the end of the world
um where did she get that from where
does she get 12 years from well she
didn't get it from science I'll tell you
that she just got it from her fevered
imagination and you know you and I can
listen to this kind of hysterical
nonsense and we can sift through it and
we can see it for what it is but kids
are not able to do that which is why
climate alarmism is child abuse
because it is psychologically
traumatizing to kids who don't know any
better you know when you tell a child
that the world is gonna end them ice
caps are gonna melt we're all gonna
drown in a few years that's abuse
that is psychological abuse that it's
traumatizing for a child to be told that
I mean I know when I was uh when I was a
kid I could remember that there the big
thing was deforestation and I was told
in school that all the trees are being
cut down and and soon enough there's not
gonna be any oxygen left in the world
and we're all gonna die and I was
terrifying to be because when you're a
kid and you know when you're an adult
you have a brain in your head and you
hear that you think okay it's like
alright calm down
like yeah I mean we should try to not
cut down all the trees and you know we
should try to plant new trees when we
cut that I mean I'm yeah fine but don't
tell me that we're all gonna die
the Amazon rainforest is being cut down
don't tell me that so as an adult I can
say that but as a child I can remember
being 13 third grade sitting in a
classroom being told this stuff and and
it was just absolutely horrifying to
hear and it scared me to death and it's
not fair to do that to kids even if you
think you're doing it for a good cause
it still does not make it okay to lie to
children it was the same kind of thing I
don't want to get off track here but it
was the same kind of thing when I was
growing up the the anti-smoking crusade
and so they were really you know they're
really intent on making sure kids don't
smoke cigarettes which is a good goal
because it's good to stop kids from
smoking cigarettes but what they told us
I can remember being taught the
impression that I was given as a kid is
that if you are even in the same room
for a few minutes as someone who's
smoking a cigarette you could get cancer
and die that that is the distinct
impression I got is that is that is that
you know it's like ingesting anthrax or
something like that which of course is
completely ridiculous but I guess what
they thought is well let's just scare
these kids scare them straight lie to
them and if in the end they don't end up
smoking then then it was worth it but
that is an ends justify the means just
wrong way of going about things and it's
the same sort of situation here it is it
is hysterical nonsense to say that the
world is coming to an end or or anything
like that
these apocalyptic predictions and and
I'm not saying that we should you know
be messing up the environment or dumping
chemicals into rivers and throwing trash
everywhere recycling is fine I mean all
that stuff is fine but you can you can
advocate for that without lying and
without being hysterical speaking of
being hysterical Eric halt house is a
meteorologist with for some reason a
huge social media
following this guy has like hundreds of
thousands of followers on Twitter and
here's what he tweeted over the weekend
he said preventing the earth from
descending into a lifeless husk of a
planet in a geological blink of an eye
is technologically possible
experts say but it work it will require
confiscating unearned wealth from
billionaires and ending the pointless
wars we've been fighting for generations
now this tweet got like 7,000 likes on
Twitter the earth is descending into a
lifeless husk and the only way to stop
it is to confiscate wealth from
billionaires now even if I agreed that
the earth is descending into a lifeless
house how does taking money from
billionaires and giving it to other
people how does that help the
environment exactly what do you how is
that I don't understand what that has to
do with the environment but of course
the bigger point here is that the earth
is not descending into a lifeless husk
yes eventually the earth will be a
lifeless husk but it's not going to be
in the blink of an eye and it's not
gonna be because you were driving an SUV
that's not gonna be the reason how
arrogant do you have to be to believe
something like that so not only is it
hysterical nonsensical dishonest but
it's also so egotistical the earth has
been around for 4.5 billion years a
billion years it has survived asteroid
strikes super volcanic eruptions ice
ages countless other cataclysmic events
but you think a couple hundred years of
industrialized Society will turn it into
a lifeless husk do you have any idea how
resilient the earth is do you have any
idea what it would take to make the
earth a lifeless husk it's gonna take a
lot more than a smokestack on a factory
I can tell you that I mean the asteroid
that wiped out the dinosaurs didn't even
make the earth a lifeless husk it made
the earth inhospitable to many forms of
life for a while
but but
the lifeless husk means the earth is
dead that's what a husk is it's a corpse
it's just it's dead it's done what he's
claiming is that the earth is going to
die and be totally destroyed
you know destroying the planet right
that's what we hear from environmental
so we're destroying the planet we could
not destroy the planet if we tried the
Sun can destroy the planet the Sun could
burp tomorrow and we would all be
incinerated that's how powerful the Sun
is a big enough asteroid could destroy
the planet a collision with another
planet could destroy our planet
it takes a cosmic scale event to destroy
a planet that is not something we could
do as I said even if we tried we could
not do that and we're not going to do
that which again does not mean that we
should just do what we want and and and
you know ruin cut down all the trees
that we want and throw trash everywhere
and and you know it's no one is saying
that but it's possible to advocate for
conservation and responsibility and
recycling and not being wasteful and all
that it's possible to advocate for those
things for those worthy worthwhile
things without being a Chicken Little
running around screaming that the sky is
falling it's possible to do and so
that's what I that's what I would
suggest all right um a basketball player
a well I say a basketball played by play
announcer I should say for the
University of Iowa Gary dolphin is his
name has been suspended for the rest of
the season and possibly it could be done
forever it could be an indefinite kind
of suspension because of a comment that
he made at the end of an Iowa versus
Maryland game over the weekend and this
allegedly was a racist comment that this
guy made Gary dolphin
I'll tell you what the comment was he
was talking is it during the postgame
show analyzing the game and he was
talking about Maryland forward Bruno
Fernando and dolphin in an effort to be
complementary dolphins said 12 threes
and 22 made baskets that's some pretty
good long-range shooting and then
Fernando was King Kong at the end of the
game so Fernando was King Kong at the
end of the game and now maybe his career
is over because of that because you
could interpret that as a racist comment
if you wanted to and the key part of
that being if you wanted to if you were
intent on seeing that as racist then you
could certainly see it as racist because
but but but if if instead you you you
decided that you wanted to cut the guy
even a little bit of slack and have even
a little bit of charity just the
smallest amount of charity in the way
that you interpret that comment you will
instead see that this is meant to be a
compliment and it of course was not
supposed to be racist he was not
referring to the guy's race obviously
but he was just saying that the player
was tough unstoppable
I'm strong dominant that it's like
saying that somebody was a monster on
the court is that racist yes if you go
around saying you know people of this
race are monsters well that's racist but
if somebody's playing a game and you say
let's guy the guy was a monster out
there that's not racist totally
different context or if it's like
comparing them to the Hulk or Superman
or any other mythical creature that's
the point and this is what just
infuriates me to no end is with this
kind of thing we all know you know if
you were
the postgame show and you saw the full
clip in context unless you're you're
crazy when you saw that you you would
know exactly what he meant there's just
no way that a halfway intelligent an
honest person could listen to that
comment and actually think that he meant
to say something racist there's just no
way there's just no way that dolphin
decided right then and there to end his
career by randomly making a racist
comment for no reason it's like we can
pretty much assume with 99.99999%
certainty that that was not his
intention but yes you could interpret it
that way if you want if you just were
determined to what to see the absolute
worst in this guy and you wanted to
destroy his life then yeah you could do
that um you could say yes you know what
his intention was to sacrifice his whole
career everything he worked for in order
to in order to throw a casual racist jab
at a player in the guise of a compliment
if you're intent on destroying this man
that's how you'll interpret it but but
why would you and be intent on
destroying him um dolphin issued a
statement by the way apologizing this
was a statement he said during the
broadcast I used the comparison when
tried to describe a talented Maryland
basketball player in no way did I intend
to offend or disparage the player I take
full responsibility for my inappropriate
word choice I offer a sea of sincere
apology to him and anyone else who was
offended
I wish the Iowa Hawkeye players coaches
and fans all very best as they headed to
the final stretch of the season I will
use this as an opportunity to grow as a
person and learn more about unconscious
bias
you know he's groveling here because he
I mean I don't blame him he's he wants
to get his job back and he's and but as
much as
I would love to see this guy issue a
statement and say you know what you
idiots you know what I meant you
despicable idiots that you're you're
gonna destroy me for no reason just
because you know just just just just for
fun you're gonna you're gonna you're
gonna intentionally misconstrue what I
said and try to destroy everything I've
worked for my whole career how dare you
you people owe me an apology now if it
were me that's the kind of statement I
would probably issue but you know maybe
that wouldn't be the most prudent step
but why isn't that enough so he
apologized he said look you know it's
not how I meant it I if you took it that
way I'm sorry I didn't mean it that way
so why isn't that enough why can't
people just say okay all right well you
know fine even if somehow you were
really offended by that and if in some
way you you really thought that he meant
it in a racist way well why can't that
be enough if somebody says something
that you know most likely could be
interpreted in an innocuous way but
there's a possibility that maybe it was
racist then why can't you just say no oh
hell-oh ii what did you mean by that
what you just said there I mean it
sounds mean maybe you could have meant
something racist and then let the person
say I don't I don't know it's um what I
meant that's um let me tell you what I
meant and once they clarify it just move
on with your life they've told you what
they meant that's not what they meant
you interpreted it wrong so what on some
kind of technicality we're gonna say
well yeah you didn't mean that but you
said the words King Kong and technically
I mean technical foul right you're done
your whole life is over it's it's just
inhumane it's it's it's to treat people
this way I mean I don't know anything
about Gary dolphin but you know just
just randomly destroying people that I
mean Gary dolphin was just an Iowa
play-by-play announcer it's not even
like this is some politically
significant person he's simply a guy who
calls basketball games and worse
all right yeah we're gonna ruin him this
is what you know I keep saying it over
and over and over again
but there's a very simple concept here
that I think a lot of people struggle to
understand and that is that you as the
listener okay you don't get to decide
when somebody is speaking as the
listener you don't get to decide what
they meant by what they said you hear it
you interpret it how you interpret it
but only they can speak to their
intentions you you cannot read their
mind you don't have ESP okay you don't
have psychic powers so they are the only
people the person who says something is
the only person on earth who can really
speak to the intention behind those
words and so if something is said by a
speaker that you find offensive the only
thing you can do is ask them what they
meant and when they tell you what they
meant you have no choice as a rational
person but just to take that and believe
it and move on that's all and and if
they say something that you know could
be interpreted in an offensive way but
you also know they didn't mean it like
that yet you still call for them to be
fired anyway then you're just a scumbag
you're just a horrible person you're a
horrible vindictive person I mean you're
a sociopath in that case and it seems
like there are a lot of sociopaths
in America all right speaking of
sociopaths I have to
mentioned one other thing and I'm loathe
to give this guy any attention but Bill
Maher on his show
launched into a lame absurd elitist
attack on red states and I want you to
watch this I'm gonna give you a clip of
it and it's really interesting because
it you're gonna feel like you unearthed
some kind of elitist time capsule from
1994 so here is um here is Bill Maher on
his show a mocking red status the blue
parts of America are having a big
prosperity party while that big sea of
red feels like their invitation got lost
in the mail and they still use the mail
they turn on the TV and all the shows
take place in a few hip cities there's
no Real Housewives of Toledo or CSI
Lubbock
there are no red carpets in Wyoming and
no one ever asks you who are you wearing
because the answer is always target
[Laughter]
there are two Americas and it seems like
one is where all the cool jobs are where
people drive Tesla's and eat artisanal
ice cream we have orchestras and theater
districts and world-class shopping we
have chef Wolfgang Puck they have Chef
Boyardee our roofs have solar panels
theirs have last year's Christmas lights
we've got legal bud they've got bud
[Music]
okay now the the worst part of that
video of course is the cackling audience
to all this all these lame jokes they're
like they're just they're just so happy
that that they can pretend to be
sophisticated by laughing at those
red-state plebs you know except
ironically if they the audience or bill
maher himself if they actually knew
anything about food culture or the craft
beer scene or any of the things that he
mentioned they would know that those
insults stop being relevant like 25
years ago I mean chef Wolfgang Puck
that's your example of some kind of you
know some sort of really trendy fancy
chef that we can't even conceal a
wolfgang puck I you can go to concours e
in the Charlotte Airport right across
from the Cinnabon and get a stale ham
sandwich for my wolfgang puck restaurant
it is not there's nothing impressive
about it whatsoever like you you go you
just walk through an airport you grab a
ham sandwich from Wolfgang Puck and get
a you know bottle of water from the
convenience store it's like that's and
that's who you choose it's and actually
some of the best food states in America
are red states Texas Louisiana Tennessee
Wisconsin and beer I mean he said well
you know red states all they do is drink
Budweiser North Carolina Missouri Texas
Indiana Montana these are all great
great great states for beer in fact the
last time I was at a bar that only had
Budweiser and Miller on tap was in
Pennsylvania and that is not a red state
and target I mean you think target is a
red state thing there are plenty of
targets in red states but I live on the
East Coast
I live in blue territory and there's a
target every 14 blocks ok target is
anything it's more of a blue state thing
so Mar is a snob who's been
cryogenically frozen in time since the
early 90s and now he's coming with them
you know Budweiser
and Wolfgang Puck references it's really
embarrassing actually I'm actually
embarrassed I almost feel bad for him
because that was such a lame just such a
lame bit I mean anytime you see a
comedian dying on stage you can't help
but feel for them a little bit because
it's so humiliating
but I will say this to Bill Maher that
you should and I say this as as someone
who you know as a conservative you
should definitely keep that up I would
even recommend doing a segment like that
every single week on your show until
2020 because if you want to ensure that
Donald Trump gets reelected then then
keep on keep keep up with that keep
heaping scorn and disdain on the vast
majority of the country geographically
keep on doing that because yeah that's
how you're gonna make sure that Donald
Trump gets gets reelected
this is this it's not a good strategy
for the left to alienate a majority of
the country and to make everyone who
doesn't live in a city feel like there
or to try to make them feel like a bunch
of like a bunch of stupid bumpkins all
you're going to accomplish is making
sure that your ideas and your
politicians are you know never see power
again and by the way I don't you know I
just I think this whole back and forth
about the cities for small towns and
where is real America Oh real America's
in the cities or real Americas in the in
the Midwest yeah I think the whole thing
is stupid on both sides personally I
mean real America is everywhere in
America America is a diverse place and I
think it's I've spent plenty of time in
cities I spent but spend plenty of time
and in small towns and everything you
know personally I'm not a big fan of the
cities I prefer the small town I prefer
having space and trees and things like
that a little
wildlife you know I prefer that but I
also think it's dumb and sometimes you
hear this from people and you know small
people in the small towns will will act
like everybody in the city they're all a
bunch of elitist that's not real America
no that's not true either you still
whole thing is stupid it doesn't really
matter where you live you no matter
where you live you can be a real
American and you know and a patriot
so indulging on that on either side is
just is foolish I think all right let's
get to a few of your emails Matt Walsh
show at gmail.com Matt Walsh show at
gmail.com if you want to email with your
questions concerns comments hate mail
this is from Michael he says hi Matt I'm
a longtime listener always enjoy your
insights on today's show you talked
about how you enjoy smoking cigars I
have many friends who also enjoy cigars
however as a faithful Catholic I have
always believed that smoking cigars or
cigarettes for that matter is akin to
desecrating the temple the Holy Spirit
as smoking is very unhealthy especially
cigars I'd love to hear your take on
this god bless hi Michael I think that's
a a perfectly valid perspective and if
you decide to avoid alcohol or you know
tobacco that's that's great you know
it's fine with me I don't personally
consider it to be a desecration of the
temple within moderation I mean of
course it's possible to abuse any
substance now
addiction to a substance is never good
so somebody who smokes three packs of
cigarettes a day yeah that's something
that they need to obviously try to stop
because it's killing them but tobacco
even nicotine it's not like heroin it's
not like you do it one time and you're
an addict I've been smoking cigars
casually for a long time I'm not
addicted I could go five months and not
smoke one especially in the winter I
tend not to because it's cold out I
don't feel like sitting out there takes
a lot of smoke a cigar so you know it's
just a casual thing for me is it a
desecration of the temple to smoke
casually no I don't you know I don't see
how that's any more of a desecration
than someone who has a sweet tooth or
someone who is you know a little bit too
sedentary or somebody who eats too
much red meat or something if it's
possible to eat too much red meat which
i don't think it is although I'm not a
doctor so I think we're allowed to enjoy
life and and I do think that look
tobacco was not invented by the devil
that was God's doing and I don't think
the first people who figured out how to
brew beer were possessed by Satan no
they were using hops and other things
that God gave us is it crazy to think
that maybe God has given us these things
to enjoy them maybe God isn't quite the
Puritan that we sometimes make him out
to be again he did invent tobacco after
all he did make grapes that can be
turned into wine
so aside from the fact that Jesus is
drinking wine and the by in the Gospels
all the time God also invented the grape
which is this very complex fruit that it
just so happens you can turn into this
delicious beverage now I know that this
logic only goes so far
psychedelic mushroom mushrooms exist in
nature too right does that make it okay
to take shrooms poison frogs exist in
nature but does that make does that mean
we should go around licking them for a
buzz opium exists in nature does that
make it okay to shoot up heroin
I think the difference here is
moderation it's not possible to do
heroin in moderation there's no such
thing as a casual social heroin user one
time could kill you
and it will certainly hook you and you
can't do heroin without getting high so
that's why obviously heroin is just bad
alcohol isn't like that you will not
become an alcoholic from a glass of beer
a glass of beer won't kill you it won't
make you drunk it's perfectly possible
to enjoy it within reason and in a
totally healthy way I know there are
plenty of people who struggle with that
and if they do then they got to stay
away from it but there are also many
millions of people probably billions
throughout history who have managed to
drink it casually socially not have a
problem so why shouldn't they tobacco
also not going to
kill you with one cigar it won't make
you high it won't hook you I'm not I'm
not wreck I'm not recommending it like
say hey kids go out and have tobacco
that's not what I'm saying
but moderation is perfectly possible so
that's where I stand if God gave us
something that can be enjoyed in
moderation without losing our senses
without possibly killing us from one
dose and that thing is enjoyable
relaxing helping maybe to to facilitate
social interaction or whatever then why
not I mean isn't that a pretty good
indication that that's why God put it
there to begin with if it falls into
that category I know there are people
who say well you know you shouldn't need
alcohol to relax your you shouldn't need
to you know have a have some booze and
in order to have a good time at a
wedding or something like that well I
mean yeah you should need it it's not
it's not a need per se but it does help
and so what it what's wrong with being
relaxed by a substance who said that
there's something wrong with that is it
wrong and take tylenol when you have a
headache I mean where do you draw the
line and why just it just seems like a
really arbitrary line to draw I can say
that some of the most edifying and
enjoyable conversations that I've had
especially with with other men is when
we're all sitting around having a cigar
and drinking some whiskey and that and I
find that to be especially if it's a you
know during the summer you're sitting
around outside you got a fire pit going
you got cigars you got you know bourbon
or whatever and you know you just have
really interesting edifying
conversations just enjoyable talk no
one's getting drunk it's just you're
sitting there having a good time
why not all right this is from Ben he
says hello why do you want to uphold the
sentiment that you're innocent until
proven guilty but are selective about
who that applies to even if you're
pitifully innocent why does Michael
Jackson get excluded from that principle
especially when all the facts stand
behind him that his accusers are lying
and accusing spend accusing specifically
for money all right let me explain this
one because I've been getting emails
like this from from the same small group
of people for the last like three weeks
and that's because like a month ago on
Twitter I briefly mentioned the fact
Michael Jackson was a creepy pervert and
I mention this in reaction to news about
the Michael Jackson documentary
documenting all of his creepy perviness
which debuted on the film festival
circuit and I think will be airing on
HBO I believe this week although his
family has been suing to try to stop the
documentary from from from being aired
but I think unsuccessfully so anyway
ever since then after a couple of tweets
about it I've had MJ's cultish fanatical
followers harassing me and and so let me
just say Ben first of all with all due
respect you do realize how weird it is
right to send someone multiple emails
defending the honor of a dead celebrity
who accused multiple was I'm accused
multiple times of pedophilia and the
only reason you like him is because he
was a good dancer I mean you realize
that that's weird to spend your time
that way it's just it's weird man it is
to be completely obsessed with some dead
celebrity because he was a good dancer
and for that reason you assume that
there's no way he could have done these
things I here's the fact of the matter
you take these accusations everything
about Michael Jackson and you apply that
to someone who can't sing and dance you
Ben would not be defending him and you
know it if this was just some random guy
you heard about all of these things
about him
you would not be rushing to to defend
his honor you're only doing that because
he's a good singer and a good dancer
that is weird
it just is Ben here's what I'll say
about Michael Jackson and I do plan to
watch the documentary which is damning
from what I've heard but Jackson was not
proven innocent the fact that he paid
off his accusers to silence them does
not prove his innocence if anything it
indicates the opposite and you know what
I think the accusations especially how
consistent they were between the
multiple accusers I think they were very
credible very believable
but I don't even need to get into that
Ben Jackson admitted sharing his bed
with little boys okay he invited little
strange boys not even related to him uh
over to his house for sleepovers and he
his bed with them that's all I need to
know I don't need to know anything else
that's it I don't need any more
information there is a zero point zero
percent chance that a man who invites a
young boy to his house to sleep in his
bed is not a pedophile there is a zero
percent point point zero percent chance
I will in every single case if you know
of any men in your neighborhood that
invite little boys to their to his house
you know over over to sleep in bed I
I care into you that person is a
pedophile one hundred percent call the
police okay then there is note and then
it just so it just so happens also
coincidentally that this guy who admits
to to to inviting little boys over to
his house for sleepover parties he just
so happens that he's also multiple--
accused of being a pedophile you think
that's a coincidence
are you insane Ben are you crazy
just because you like the way he dances
you're gonna pretend that you don't see
the connection a guy invites little boys
over sleeps in his bed
oh and what do you know he's accused of
being a pedophile either one knows no
way no way no way not a guy who could
dance like that no way and don't give me
you know Michael Jackson's defender said
they'll say well no he was just a child
at heart he was so sweet and innocent
he's just look at me so it's a sweet and
innocent guy and that's why he's a child
I hope you don't have kids with an
attitude like that I mean would you let
your child would you let your child go
sleep in a grown man's bed on the basis
that the man is just a child at heart
he's so innocent Michael Jackson had
turned his house into a into a you know
Neverland it we will throw it with it
with a you know carnival rides and
everything you think it was because he
was innocent at heart I mean seriously
you you don't need to be a genius to
figure this out
he had all this stuff to lure children
over Oh what do you know he's sleeping
in their bed Oh what do you know he's
accused of being a pedophile that's
because he was a pedophile definitely
I mean there is zero doubt in my mind
and and honestly you you michael jackson
defenders should be absolutely ashamed
of yourself
I mean it's so embarrassing and
humiliating for you and as I said if you
have kids
I certainly hope I if you have kids I
hope that you're much more cautious with
them then you appear to be when you
defend Michael Jackson so that's all
alright um we'll leave it there thanks
for watching everybody thanks for
listening Godspeed